welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
remain seated starts to be available
today we're all comedy dynamics
platforms are found places like right
here on the home of DirecTV can be on
DirecTV Apple TV spectrum Comcast and of
course Amazon Prime video check out
again remain seated available today from
again the comedy dynamics platform and
the comedy from the very dynamic Larry
the Cable Guy here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Larry I've never been
called dynamic I appreciate well you
know what Larry I just uh that's the
it's called comedy dynamics and I just
figured you're the comedy dynamic guy
when it comes to that for I'd say it
feels like forever what you know I did a
I did a little major thing for your kids
that's right my kids can't get enough of
that Larry did you get enough of that
that's right you must get that all the
time right what's that you must get that
all the time right you know it's really
cool I do get it a lot and I always you
know I'll get requests all the time so I
usually take a day a week and I'll sit
down and I'll do some birthday calls for
some people that have kids in a hospital
or something you know and I'll do little
major stuff it's fun I enjoyed it's
funny when I walking down the street or
something somebody with their kids and
no parents you know they'll recognize me
as me and then they'll go to the kids
the loser that is that's mater and they
kind of look at me and then I go just
like imagine with that guitar boy you
got to see their face I mean it it's
pretty cool that almost killed me though
you know I put on seven hundred pounds
to do that Terry come on hustle
that's that rich that's how good I am at
voiceovers I'm the only person that puts
on weight to do voices well I mean you
got to become you got to become the tow
right you're a man you're a method tow
mater is basically what you're saying
I'm taking it off I tell you this whole
staying-in and be in quarantine I told
my wife I said I'm not going to allow
myself to sit around and eat all day so
we're not as you know in Nebraska
there's not that many cases so they
allow us you know we could if we want to
we can go for walks and stuff like that
and believe it or not I'm down about 21
pounds since you're in the February look
at you Larry I mean like you're you've
lost the quarantine 20 that's pretty
impressive man so you know I knew I had
to do something Pauline and January I
did two jumps and I had to get off of
the trampoline I wasn't tired I had to
get my kids out of a tree that's that's
the counterbalance that's the
counterweight you got to take that into
effect you got to take that into account
when you're hopping on the trampoline
Larry that's what I check out what's
going on somebody has leaked naked
pictures of me on the Internet no is
that right what is that what what
happened there Larry well unfortunately
the pictures are from an overhead late
night camera so I must have been on my
way to Arby's I love this I'm playing
the straight guy - Larry the Cable Guy
right here in the Rich Eisen show
fantastic that's what I do for a living
I do love it you know you know what's
hilarious I got to tell you cuz I do i
do all one-liners you know it's one
after another I've always been a saint
of all the old-time one-liner gryson so
I remember the first time I was ever on
The Tonight Show my manager said don't
let Jay say anything because he oh he'll
interrupt your punchlines I said don't
worry I can handle it I'll never forget
the first time I went on The Tonight
Show Jay Leno introduced me said so
how's it going Larry
and I did not stop talking for eight
nights and I don't think you got one
word it was great we call that in the
sports radio business sports talk basis
that's pulling at Joe Theismann right
Chris that's winning you just yeah Joe
Joe thighs the over-under on Joe
Theismann's first answer to your first
question is about four and a half
minutes and I'd suggest you take the
over sometimes Larry how long was his
first answer to your first question on
the phone you know what it was we were
talking about some kind of a cream to
put on your back so he was all business
but that way I can another Terry
Bradshaw the same way I remember a long
time ago when I was coming through the
ranks you know Foxworthy is a buddy of
mine and he was sitting at the house
there cellphone ringing I looked at it
and I go holy smokes it's Carrie
Bradshaw
I was out stoked I go champ it's
Bradshaw he goes huh let it go sometimes
Carrie just never gets off the phone and
I don't have time Larry the Cable Guy I
would pay to watch a conversation with
you and Terry Bradshaw that would be
what we call good eats that would be
amazing he was actually I had him in one
of my Christmas specials I did three
Christmas specials he played the
bartender and one of my Christmas
specials I got to tell you it was fun it
was one of my favorite scenes I ever did
in a Christmas special I love the guy he
just he's just all full of happiness and
joy he's great yeah Terry I think was it
was it Smokey and the Bandit - was that
his was that his big film debut back in
the day it was Hooper or something like
that I just remember him Terry's been a
Cannonball Run maybe I don't know
Cannonball Run I can't I know what
you're talking about right now I'm
having a brain fart but it was me me -
Larry the Cable Guy here on the Rich
Eisen show
you have an NFL team that's you're a fan
of specifically well yeah I do you know
I grew up a huge Oakland Raider fan I
don't know why I just I remember when I
was a little kid I sat down when I was
about six years old and my grandpa was
watching a black-and-white TV it was a
Steelers Raiders game and I said that's
my favorite team and he said which one I
said the ones in the white and that's
happened to be the Raiders I loved their
helmets and then from that day on I just
became a huge Raider fan
and then about somewhere around the time
they got Jay Schrader kinda I kind of
wobbled and and and then I was living in
Florida from Nebraska and so the
Buccaneers were closer to me so you know
I still followed the Raiders I was kind
of searching for another team and then
in the 90s I saw Brett Favre in the late
part was wearing a get er done Larry the
Cable Guy t-shirt in a spring game and
then I just became a huge Packer fan and
then I married my wife my wife went to a
school in a small town in Wisconsin so I
just learned I just adopted the Packers
and went full bore Packers but I will
say I know it's a crime to like two
teams but I like both of them I like the
Raiders in the Packers that's fine I
mean it's certainly if Favre is wearing
a shirt with your phrase on it I mean
that's the end of that Larry I mean that
I mean yeah and I actually went to like
three games I got to sit in this box
next to Deanna my wife was there and
went down and ate nachos in cheese with
this special recipe I mean he was he was
awesome now I do feel bad though because
I know more about the Raiders and I do
the Packer that's fine
that's all right can I get me K this
quick story I remember before I ever got
in the Gulf I got into golf about 10
years ago but I was working as a at an
outdoor event beautiful and I wish I
could remember the name as in Northern
California overlooking a huge
late and they always had a golf
tournament there and I went there I
guess I was the entertainment for the
golf tournament and they asked me if I
want to go to the pairings party and I
said now I don't go up I don't know what
is I'm just gonna go backstage kind of
enjoy the scenery go over some jokes and
so I go back today he came back in
scuzzball we should went down there they
were asking if you were going to come
down there so what is it a pairing party
she said well every year we have a golf
tournament and it celebrates an NFL
football team and this year it was the
world champion 1976 Raiders I about
crapped my pants I said you've got to be
kidding me
and I said are they coming the show she
said yeah a lot of them are in your
meet-and-greet and bye guys that night I
met ray guy and pretty Biletnikoff and
slipped branch and and I mean it was
awesome and there was that was one of my
biggest drills in comedy being on stage
and looking at the third row and
watching Freddie bullet a [ __ ] doubled
over his last as long as you didn't
shake hands with Lester Hayes because
your hand would have stuck to his he
wanted to stay backstage because my
opening act was from West Virginia and
when I managed II was from West Virginia
and so he stayed backstage with and
stood off the side of the stage and for
about an hour and a half after the show
he was bitching at all the sportswriters
about not making the house man man they
don't know what the hell they're talking
about it's not how far you hit the ball
it's where you put the damn football
that's exactly right
you're not wrong I love it Larry the
Cable Guy here on the Rich Eisen show
did you ever did you base your initial
act about the Cable Guy on a specific
cable guy did you is there a real cable
guy that that that launched this ship
Larry no you know
rich I grew up on a pig farm in
southeast Nebraska real town to 1200 and
I went to college at a Baptist College
in Georgia and my roommate was from
Dalton Georgia mother was from Beaumont
Texas okay and when I started then I
then when I started doing stand-up of
course one of the first two meetings I
met was Foxworthy okay
and of course I was always integrated in
the southern culture from going to move
into Florida and going to school in
Georgia then I met Jeff and you know I
just started doing characters on stage
and Jeff and I used to sit at the Lana
brake spring training games in West Palm
Beach all the time and and he's like my
adopted brother I mean we're so much
alike but we would sit there and we
would just rip off each other and we
didn't we just made up stories and so I
remember we'd be sitting there and one
time Jeff would just lean over and go
hey Jubal did did Peggy get that potato
salad in or did she forget about that on
the truck and I was like all right you
they came and got that last week she was
the kids were poisoned and we would just
make up story
and so one day I just when I was doing
stand-up I went on stage and I was
trying to find I originally it was a it
was a rodeo bull rider didn't get much
response and then remember cable guy
came to my house he was confused about
the house he was ahead he couldn't find
a house so I made a whole thing about
this cable guy and it just stuck and it
got big laughs and so I got asked to do
a character on that on the radio station
and in the rest is pretty much history
just kind of kept getting funnier and
funnier and growing and growing and I'll
be honest I never in a million years
ever thought of doing it onstage
right it just happened
I was at a comedy club in Sarasota and
my buddy les mccurdy put Larry the Cable
Guy aka
Dan Whitney which is my real name and he
I mean it sold out two shows in like 30
minutes and I got done signing
autographs and
and idle it was crazy so he told me he
said you think you can do your whole
show like that and I said well dadgum of
course I can I can Punk like redneck all
day long I mean that's who I hang out
with we're all buddies so I went on
stage and I remember I put on when I
drove over in it was a pair of lace-up
Roper boots a pair of jeans a cut off
Nebraska t-shirt and a nascar hat and I
went on stage for the first time and you
know the rest is history it's just it's
a complete gift of God I mean I
everything that's happened to me in my
career it just man it just happened I
never really thought it out I just
wanted to be a funny comedian and make a
pretty good living that shot my loved
and man things just started opening and
it started with you riffing with Jeff
Foxworthy watching Dale Murphy and Terry
Foster played for the Braves Glen Harbor
I haven't thought of that name in
forever I remember him oh yeah
Paul bird message yes they replayed one
of my tweets yesterday but one is like
probably the third time I've ever went
on stage at an open mic night was at a
dance club in Boca Raton Florida and I
had made friends with Zane Smith and
Duane ward the superstation I mean we're
talking TV a superstation you know skip
Carey you're talking you're talking old
school like Sutton and those guys on the
side of the stage to support me and my
like my third time up and but yeah I was
a huge huge Braves fan still am today
and it's always such a thrill for me
when I get in the charity golf event and
you know there's the group in front of
me Smoltz Maddux and glass and you know
and our
these now I know about it's just oh my
god shall I pinch myself every time I
blame you though well you definitely
want their stick in your in your group
that's for damn sure you want that you
you want to play I mean those guys are
phenomenal at golf all three of them
yeah they know it's insane
so now and now you've got remain seated
available today where all of comedy
dynamics network platforms are available
tell me about this one
Larry yeah you know what I don't really
pray much from what I told my wife I
didn't I said I didn't think I could
write anymore Walmart jokes but by god I
found seven more minutes but you know
it's like I said I was always a fan of
the quick one liner setup punch guys and
there's not a lot of us out there
anymore you know akari on and Jeffrey
Ross and there's a few of us but it's
just a fun style and I love it and so
that's that's basically what it is you
know I hadn't done a my own solo album
I've got three or four of them out but I
haven't done one since like 2000 10 or
11 because I've done other projects like
Jeff Bill and I did them idiots and Jeff
and I travel together and we did we've
been thinking and so when you're doing
one-liners you know it takes a while to
get a whole new hour so one day they
just called and asked me it's been a
long time since I've done one I looked
at my act like a man I really only need
to write about another 15 minutes and I
can do one so let's go ahead and do it
and so I worked on it for about a year
and man it's just like you know it's
just like the other regular stuff just
quick one-liners about different topics
now it's the only thing it different now
is I got kids and I'm a lot of older and
I'm a lot smarter and you know I they're
you know I make sure that everything's
the so people can laugh at it so I don't
put any politics in it anymore I think
people are sick of that I just want to
be funny make people laugh
and I think I would call it I told my
wife the other day as pg13 pretty good
for 13 minutes I love it phenomenal and
the album is going to be available on
April 10th through Sirius XM Spotify
Amazon music Apple music Pandora
SoundCloud and more before I let you go
Larry we're having a conversation here
just apropos of nothing
do you like the ends of bread or do you
just stay away from that when you're
eating a sandwich what are you so I love
the ends my wife gets mad because I take
the ends and she says that keeps the
wrists and the bread safe but I
immediately go to the front in the back
I don't know why but I've always loved
the end oh so your your wife objects
because the ends protect the loafs I
guess longevity and when you take okay
and your go-to sandwiches what Larry
what's your go-to sandwich my sammich
well I mean if I make it with bread I
mean obvious I'm achiever but okay if I
make a sammich it is ham it's honey ham
with American cheese and Doritos and
mayonnaise pushed together impressed
with ends of bread with end and that
would get it done that gets her done I
bet Larry thanks for the call man let's
chat again and thanks again for doing
that recording for my kids a couple
years ago they loved it they absolutely
flipped out you bet remain seated first
stand-up special in over a decade for
Larry the Cable Guy available we're all
comedy dynamics platforms are available
the comedy dynamics Network again places
like Amazon Prime video comcast spectrum
Apple TV DirecTV and more thanks to the
Kohler you guys ladies and gentlemen